comme une odeur de représailles dans
l'air au pakistan la colère gronde
alimentée par la résurgence d'un
sentiment anti français
depuis une semaine les affrontements se
multiplient entre la police et les
partisans d'un parti islamiste radicale
le tehrik est l'e bike pakistanais dit
tlpc milliers de partisans protestent
contre l'arrestation de leur chef ce
lundi sa drisse vie inculpé au titre de
la loi antiterroriste exiger l'expulsion
immédiate de l'ambassadeur de france
l'ambassade qui s'inquiètent de cette
nouvelle vague d'animosité dirigée
contre l'hexagone en raison des menaces
sérieuses qui pèsent sur les intérêts
français au pakistan
il est recommandé aux ressortissants
français et aux entreprises françaises
de quitter provisoirement le pays
dans cette campagne dirigée contre la
france
résonnent les mots d' emmanuel macron en
octobre dernier le chef de l'état avait
défendu le droit à la caricature et au
blasphème
au nom de la liberté d'expression suite
à l'assassinât de sa mère pattie ce
professeur tué en octobre dernier en
région parisienne pour avoir montré des
caricatures de mahomet le prophète de
l'islam à ses élèves
des propos qui avaient déclenché des
manifestations au pakistan et dans
plusieurs autres pays musulmans ainsi
que des appels au boycott de produits
français
en réaction le premier ministre
pakistanais imran khan avait convoqué
l'ambassadeur de france accusant
emmanuel macron d'attaqué l'islam et de
mener une campagne islamophobe sous
couvert de liberté d'expression
le président macro aurait pu jouer
l'apaisement et refuser l'espace aux
extrémistes plutôt que de créer une
polarisation et une marginalisation
supplémentaires qui conduisent
inévitablement à la radicalisation
il est regrettable qu'il ait choisi
d'encourager l'islamophobie en
s'attaquant à l'islam plutôt qu aux
terroristes qui pratiquent la violence
le tehrik elle les bayik reproche
aujourd'hui aux gouvernants
man pakistanais de ne pas avoir respecté
l'accord qui aurait été conclu suite à
ces protestations visant à expulser
l'ambassadeur de france en réponse le
parti a de nouveau réclamé en début de
semaine le départ du diplomate bloquant
en partie les deux plus grandes villes
du pays
lahore et karachi ainsi que la capitale
islamabad le gouvernement pakistanais a
annoncé ce mercredi son intention
d'interdire le mouvement tentant cette
fois-ci l'apaisement tout est sous
contrôle
la police et les forces paramilitaires
vont gérer la situation avec la grâce de
dieu
tous les citoyens français vivant au
pakistan sont en sécurité et il n'y a
aucun danger pour eux mais en attendant
les relations entre paris et islamabad
reste très tendue au pakistan où la
question de plus en plus politisée du
blasphème est explosive ridiculiser ou
insulté le prophète mahomet reste
passible de la peine de mort